you
[Music]
my name is Kirsten moss and I'm the Dean
of Admissions and financial aid at
Stanford and really looking forward to
our session a regional session on New
York today thank you for coming you know
I'm a little I'm a little sad because
every summer I get a chance to come out
to New York and meet some of our
prospects out there and with the global
pandemic that's obviously not possible
today and we really have thought about
how do we bring Stanford to you in a
still personal way but do it online so
what we would have done last year is an
information session an admissions
officer like myself would tell you about
the program what's distinctive and
really talk about how to put your best
foot forward in the application process
and then the second thing we would do is
hear from a panel of students and alumni
who have experienced the GSB and what we
seen from my research from our surveys
is that's really the most important
thing for most of our prospects to see
themselves at the school understand that
experience so today we're really gonna
focus on that for 45 minutes we know and
zoom we don't want to keep you on the
screen for you know an hour and a half
so we're just gonna do this part we're
gonna do panelist introductions first
I'll do that and then after that we're
gonna have a moderated Q&A so I'll start
off with a couple questions but it's
really gonna be up to you to submit your
questions via the chat box the Q&A box
so I know what's on your mind and we can
make sure you get the most out of the
session as possible and just a reminder
that this is really the panel part of
the session so if you're interested
after spending some time with us and
want to learn more I highly encourage
you to come to one of our virtual
information session sessions so you can
learn more about the admissions process
and what you can do to put your best
foot forward in your application now one
more tip I think as we're starting to
head in the session is as you meet our
panelists they all come from very
different backgrounds one thing you can
do as a prospect and thinking about your
application process is really we ask you
questions like what matters most and why
and your essays or what do you want to
get out of your MBA
why Stanford as you listen to students
stories I'm sure that will help you
begin reflecting on what what you were
interested in accomplishing so I hope
you keep that in the back of your mind
as you hear from our panelists now I'm
gonna ask we have five panelists today
and we purposely selected them from the
region of New York so they've all gone
to school on the west coast and moved
back to the east coast but we've made
sure that they're coming from a variety
of industries healthcare and gaming
consulting tech but also different
functions so we have a chief of staff
and product marketing general manager
and I'm gonna start off with asking Jack
to introduce themselves as class and the
first question I'd love you to answer
each of the panelists is tell me about
an academic experience that was
meaningful to you at Stanford awesome
thanks Kirsten um so Jack Armstrong
originally from the UK before business
school I was an operational
restructuring consultant so I
specialized in turnaround and
transformation projects all across the
world after business school I'm going to
work in private equity operations so I'm
going to be chief of staff hopefully a
company on the East Coast just outside
of New York working on behalf of the
fund with the health care pharma company
to hopefully drive some improvements
over the next few years
terms of my favorite academic experience
I think MGE for me as a whole is my
favorite class of business school M G
stands for managing growing enterprises
and its really taking a lot of what we
learn about leadership and management
and applying in to real-world situations
so we have the protagonist of a case in
the class we work through the case the
professor is really drilling and digging
and make it roleplay various scenarios
and then we get to hear what actually
happened is now coming so for me it was
fantastic experience because it took all
of the learning that we've done and
applied to in practice in the classroom
I me had a chance to speak to some of
the amazing guests awesome fantastic and
I'm gonna leave this panelist
description up here while they speak
about their back the first question and
their names and then we'll take it off
so you can see their faces
so Michelle
let us now everyone i'm michelle
Baumgartner I'm calling from the the
woods of northern Wisconsin so fight
break up
bear with me but I am originally from
Toronto and Canada so I grew up there
but I went to college at the University
of Minnesota I worked for Accenture in
strategy consulting before the GSB I did
an internship at we work in New York
last summer and then I'm going to be
starting in a couple weeks as a product
marketing manager at Unity Technologies
so it's a gaming startup in San
Francisco and then my favorite Jack like
almost stole mine but I have a backup
mine I have to say so I was a I was a
business undergrad and I was in some
ways somewhat skeptical that I've and
it's gonna be repeating a lot of the
same classes but I think one thing I was
just really I fell in love with and I
was pleasantly surprised to find out a
business school was there are these sort
of more interpersonal and intrapersonal
classes that I've really enjoyed and
well I'm sure talking more about them
but one of them was touchy feely
I also took art of self coaching and
life's a consequence and so I I think
those types of classes the more soft
skill classes are really the highlight
of my experience Eric let's move to you
sure hi everyone
so I think I was born and raised in New
York City so shout out to all the New
York City folks on the line and I joked
that I grew up as the son of an abstract
painter and a lung doctor so I was just
blown away from the beginning and the
way that showed up for me professionally
is I just post GSB I worked at McKinsey
before joining capsule as Director of
Product before that I was on design
thinking consulting so a lot of deep
user research and creating new products
and services and I would say one of the
standout academic experiences to me was
in Rob Siegel's industrialists dilemma
class where you have some of the titans
of industry come in and talk about how
they view innovation disruption and
what's happening in their industry and
then you also
have some of the disruptors who were
coming in so hearing you know for
example from an autonomous vehicles see
right after hearing from Ford CEO about
the future of mobility
I think created a really rich
cross-functional perspective that I
loved and gained a lot from Aditi why
don't you start
I'm sure hi I'm a DT Banga I'm graduated
from the GSB in the class of 2015 so
it's been five years which is a little
crazy I can't believe how quickly the
time is gone before the GSB I started
out working in management consulting I
was at the monitor group which is now an
by Deloitte and then I spend two years
working in mobile gaming as a product
manager actually first startup that was
started by members of the class of GSB
2010 and then after that after the GSB I
was initially based out in the Bay Area
working for Apple for their movies and
TV division and then my husband and I
are both from New York originally so a
couple of years ago we relocated back
here I am now at Instagram working on
our media partnerships team focusing
specifically on shopping so working with
just a number of brands and media
partners on you know commerce related
activities on the platform my favorite
class of the GSB let's see so I actually
I also really loved Mg but another one
that was I was a big fan of is this
class called leadership and
entertainment which is typically a
second year elective but you can also
take it as a first year and it's just an
incredible speaker series where every
session you have members of different
parts of the entertainment industry is
it and you know talk about what it's
like to work in the industry so
really get that real-world perspective
great thank you
and we'll how about you heyo how's it
going
I graduated from GSB last year so I've
been out for about a year now
before that I had worked at Bain &
Company in Chicago and before that had
had gone to Notre Dame for me you know
Eric actually stole mine I love the
industrialist dilemma as well
but my probably my second favorite class
because I also was doing my masters in
debt at the time was class called
leading us schools which was taught by a
practitioner who runs the largest
charter network in Los Angeles so you
would fly up from Los Angeles once a
week to teach our class and he brought
in ten speakers over the course of the
year who had tried and in most cases had
failed to turn around large US public
school systems and I thought that was
fascinating because I was so topical to
a lot of the big education debates we're
having many of them had a business
background and also many of them had
actually failed and so you got to hear
from people who I think we we saw had
succeeded but others who had not
succeeded and talked about what the
difference is driving that might have
been well thank all of you for the
introductions and I'm going to the chat
right now and one of the first questions
which is great since we're doing the New
York Region is Caroline wanted to know
could you talk about the GSP network in
New York City and I've heard this a lot
as I'm out on the road that students
realize many of our alumni love the Bay
Area and stay so how was it to both come
back and what's a community like they're
now and maybe a DT could toss could
speak to that and then Eric because you
guys have been out the longest it's it's
great actually
so it's funny I am guessing in absolute
numbers you know it's smaller than the
bay area but kind of maybe it's because
it is a smaller community I actually
find that I spend a lot more time with
the GSB community here in New York in
the Bay Area I think the bulk of my GSB
time was spent with my close friends
my own class the less so with members of
other classes or partaking in some of
the more optional activities that you
can do after you graduate so things like
the women's circle which is an ability
to kind of form a network of women
across different GSB graduating years
and you come together you know once a
month and just talk about like both
professional and personal topics and
that's something that I'm participating
in here so in some ways I found that I'm
I've tapped into more of the GSB
resources based out in New York and I
think there's also something exciting
about like you meet somebody else from
the GSB here in New York and you kind of
feel this immediate like kindred spirit
and it feels a little bit more special
because there might be fear of you so I
found that it's been a fun way to bond
with people as well awesome how about
you Eric well said I echo and agree with
everything and the only piece I'll add
on is because people who were
self-selecting to go to New York it's a
slightly more active choice I think it
tends to have that extra special sense
of community because of it which I yeah
said Eric how did you think about
recruiting trying to get back out to New
York when you were your second year was
that challenge anger yeah it's a great
question
I personally ended up taking it starting
with McKinsey in California and then
transitioning back to New York and I
think there are a lot of people who make
the choice to stay for a year two or
three in the Bay Area and then either
stay forever or later move back because
there is kind of this special moment
that can happen just after graduating to
be with a large portion of the class
when it came to coming back to New York
it really helped to be able to reach out
the alumni network like genuinely it was
it was extremely helpful and
[Music]
honestly during school I know a lot of
people or I know some people who it took
an extra effort to recruit back and
forth with New York but I think the
folks who determined that was what they
wanted to do all achieved it awesome
that's great one of the questions that
have come in at us about leadership from
Andrew which leadership experience at
the GSB was most transformative for you
and how everyone mentioned their
favorite classes but would love to learn
more specifically about how it
transformed those leadership
capabilities so maybe we'll start with
Michelle and Jack you guys are recent
you know it's tough with mind I'm sure
some of these things for you yeah I'm
I'm kind of caught between sharing two
experiences but I think what came to
mind first was so I was in this class
called startup garage which is a pretty
popular class it's application based so
I think that so I've always had this
interest I've only really worked before
the GSB yet really big companies with
Accenture very kind of the classic for
watch fortune 500 companies and so I had
this interest in working for a smaller
company I'm doing my internship there
and then ultimately you know joining a
small start-up after after the GSB so I
think it was just really helpful for me
to get this taste of what is it like to
basically start with nothing but an idea
with four people and you know be
together in a room you know I we
probably worked about 20 hours a week
plus on this idea and with classmates
that you know you think are your friends
and you know you really don't know
someone and tell you start working with
them and so not that we had you know
there was obviously conflict but there
was also just like wonderful moments of
like wow you know you're yours you're
great at specializing this and you
specialize this but I want to learn
about this so I think I learned a lot
about just working with people and and
just leadership in general and how do
you know if you have a different
direction on this idea how do you sort
of voice it and get you know the other
three people to go along with it so I
think that was that was
highlight what was the product just out
of curiosity for those who don't know
what startup for at this it's oh so are
we started with an idea so our idea was
basically as I mentioned I worked it we
work last summer I also I also have an
art major so our idea was basically
there's this there's this crazy stat
that is only 5% of films that are
produced actually make it to theaters
now obviously different nothing's in
theaters right now but so there's
basically all this all this content
that's out there that basically doesn't
find distribution and might go direct
Netflix or you know direct to another
platform and so we were basically
interested and you know is there a way
to Spacek allele Everage underutilized
spaces so say like a coffee shop that
opened that closes down 7 p.m. could we
rent it until 9:00 pull you know bring a
portable projector and basically stream
a movie for a you know budding film
director and so we were kind of
interested in this kind of Airbnb for
small format cinema we called her self
minima it actually the company has sort
of pivoted and I'm I'm no longer
involved which I can expand on later but
yeah it was it was a really just
fascinating experience with kind of the
intersection of you know awesome thank
you how about you jerk how did your
leadership transform at the GSB yeah
great question I think for me the course
that was most impactful was touchy-feely
or interpersonal dynamics I think the
reason for that is because you know the
GSB teaches you many leadership models
but doesn't tell you there's a right way
because it's all individual to you as a
leader so I think leading to that then
interpersonal dynamics for me was the
most impactful because there helped me
understand myself and the impact that I
have on people out of all the courses of
the GSB the most which I can then
transition to well how do I then show up
then what does that mean it my own
leadership style this was a very
interesting class as a Brit the thought
of being sat in a room with eleven
people but no real agenda
what we think about each other with
police Gary as we have a way in the UK
of saying everything but what we think
so for me it's just fascinating to
really spend time with a group of peers
and learn about the impact that you have
on them and how other people impact you
and take those learnings and then apply
it to well how does that mean that I
show up as a person and as a leader is
there I'm an example I'm not gonna put
you on the spot you don't have to give
us it sometimes it's hard to understand
what the concrete learning is and I
think that wasn't a question
of something you learned in touchy-feely
yeah so I think one of the things I
learned was I'll give you a real basic
example I use humor a lot to defuse
situations and sometimes that works and
sometimes that doesn't and so what was
really great for it for me was
understanding when taking the heat out
of a situation or using humor to build
the group is useful and actually you
were an insert attractor and so that was
just one example of hundreds of things
that I learned but just getting enough
reps to understand okay this is a really
useful skill but I have to choose one to
use it at the right time I love that so
it sounds like managing conflict
productively and what are the tools
that's great thank you I'm gonna go to
the next question
so Diego's asking from New Jersey can
you spend a little time telling us about
why you decided to go to business school
so some a pivot of industries and others
haven't and wanted a little insight into
that and will maybe we'll start with you
because you you didn't pivot industries
and decide to go to business school
maybe you could share that yeah I mean
it for me I think there were there were
kind of three things that that let me to
take the business school experience one
was I wanted the kind of a safe
opportunity to to test out other things
even though I knew I was going back to
bein business school was kind of an
awesome way for me to think about what I
wanted to do long term so I did my
masters in education at the same time
and I got the chance to work with a lot
of different
nonprofits while I was in b-school and
kind of understand where I want to fit
into that space down the road and then
the second thing for me was to build a
network outside of just my college peers
and my company and in particular build a
network that was going to be
international and that has been really
amazing we can talk a little bit about
it later but I think that the GSB
network is more powerful than I could
ever even have possibly imagined I
remember like two weeks into school
someone posted on our slack channel that
one of her friends had gotten into
trouble in South Sudan and she was like
do you know anyone we can call and
within like five minutes like three or
four people had given her the names of
like diplomats or ambassadors or people
in South Sudan and I was like well if
the GSB can can give us contacts in
South Sudan there's probably nowhere in
the world that we're not gonna have kind
of people at our back and then for me
finally you know I was just really kind
of burned out after three years of work
I was I was tired I wanted the chance to
kind of refresh and what I found was at
Stanford like got me excited again about
a lot of the things that I was working
on helped me to step back think about my
career is not like a couple of years as
a hard work but really is kind of a
40-year journey and all the interesting
places that could take me so those were
the reasons that I ended up and I think
the GSB kind of knocked it out of the
park on all those dimensions and how's
it feel to be back at Bain now how are
you different in the in the role now so
that's why you win if you look back what
was the value for you you know one thing
I think that I was talking to a few
people about this who who had done
consulting and then got back to very
similar roles in consulting and we all
felt way better at our jobs and that
actually in some ways was not something
that we were expecting like there were a
lot of reasons and things we were
expecting to be school I actually wasn't
expecting to feel that much better
because so much of what you learned is
learned on the job but I think it really
helped with maturity with being able to
step back and and you just you know
during b-school you have the chance to
examine so many cases to meet with so
many important speakers that it almost
feels like it gave me like greater
gravitas and a greater ability to like
bring in experiences that I had seen at
the GSB and I've actually used a lot of
what I learned in classes frameworks or
ways of thinking or case
and that that has surprised me been kind
of a nice and pleasant surprise awesome
how about a Michelle I didn't give you I
didn't give you a heads up early how are
you thinking about pivoting from into
gaming and product marketing yeah
totally so I mentioned I was at
Accenture I was there for three years
but my my background is is somewhat
unique I was told I at least at my
university of see one that has ever
majored in finance and fine art so my
majors just the story behind that is I'm
passionate about both things I love
business I think like business is kind
of everything but then I also love you
know I'm a film junkie I love going to
Sundance actually lived in Park City for
four years and so I knew I always had
this interest in entertainment I did I
didn't work with a few media
entertainment clients when I was at
Accenture and I just I really liked that
I liked it was like the most hip clients
I kind of had but I knew I wanted to do
something smaller and something more
creative I I can't say I felt super
creative and my role and was really
leveraging and kind of playing to that
strengths and so I came back to business
school I was interested in in in you
know one kind of pivoting industries but
also being in more of an operating role
in in a product role close to the
business and in operations and so I
ended up sort of for the summer trying
something out at we work in an operating
role and actually really liked that type
of role but I wasn't quite in the
industry that I wanted and so I was able
to find something at a small gaming
startup for full-time and so you know I
think it was a result of lots of
networking with alumni just speaking
with them you know I mentioned the
startup garage experience really
impacting kind of my interest in in
entertainment and specifically gaming
and so that was sort of my rationale for
coming back and hopefully goes well
would I start in a couple weeks awesome
and the next question was about the
culture and IDT I'm gonna ask this one
to you
Elissa is asking what makes it
ESP culture unique and what sets it
apart from any other MBA program so I
don't expect you to speak about other
programs that I as a Dean of Admissions
I keep calling it magic and that's
pretty high-level how do you do how you
describe it so what tactically is it
like to be part of the culture oh my
gosh um I mean it is magical it's hard
to sometimes sum it up into words but I
think you know what really stands out to
me is how supportive of a program it is
you know I think I was always interested
in getting my MBA I over the course of
like the first years that I was working
got a better and better understanding of
what I hope to get out of the program
many many reasons for being kind of
similar to well in terms of you know
really it's a safe space to experiment
and learn I used to look at the other
people who were trying you at MBAs and
really admired their skills in terms of
how to manage teams or work with teams
you know their presence you know their
ability to present well but I think what
I just didn't expect going into it was
how I'd come out of it with the closest
friends of my life like you know truly
truly like my lifelong friends I I got
married a couple years ago and all of my
you know most of my bridal party was
from the GSB and I didn't expect that
going into you into business school I
kind of thought I'd found my you know
closest friends in college and
everything but I think there's just
something different and you know maybe
part of it is it's just such an it's a
in some ways a very intense two years
right it's busy you know between classes
and extracurriculars and the social
component it's quite busy and then the
kinds of classes you're taking you know
to go through experiences like
interpersonal dynamics they're not easy
courses or startup garage you know where
you're really learning how to kind of
work with each other in a different way
um I think what I just didn't
was how how helpful and supportive
everyone would be you know you ask
somebody for guidance or for advice or
you want to talk to them about what it
was like to work in this industry or
that or you know you don't know how to
do your operations homework or
accounting homework and everyone will
drop everything to help you and I think
that's pretty special and I I can't
speak to whether that sets it apart
necessarily from other programs but he I
guess it wouldn't be on my expectations
is there someone else who wants to jump
in any of the other panelists who feel
strongly about the culture all right
Jack I can quickly jump in and so so the
community feel is is amazing as was just
described but like one small example
would be now I'd spoken to a friend and
said on i'm thinking of recruiting for
these kind of roles you know in passing
in the coffee shop and then two days
later I'm walking through campus through
Times Square and he stops me he says but
just so you know these two companies are
on campus in the next two days I spoke
to them I gave them your name let me
know if you need any help let me know if
you want to chat through anything and
Mike went on his way
I had forgotten had even told them the
type of thing that I was interested in
and he'd gone out of his way then to
think about who he knew you think about
who he could put me in touch with coach
me through the process and and that's
not unusual for homework for people for
events for trips or for any class I
think people are always thinking about
their classmates that frightens you how
they can help and support and how they
can be there I think that's just one
example in a professional context of how
it happened but happens in a personal
context all the time that's awesome I
want to make sure we cover the global
experience so Eric maybe you could did
you you're nodding I see your head we
want to share we have a global
experience requirement there are many
ways that you can fulfill that as a
student but perhaps talk to what you did
so I
to do a couple experiences both formal
and informal informal as many classmates
were from various countries wanted to
create experiences for people to come
and you know walk a little bit in their
shoes and those were some of my my
favorite experiences two former ones I
did the step program which was an
exchange program we'd seen hi University
in China I also did a global study trip
which to Mexico and the Mexico trip I'd
been to Mexico briefly before but it was
a experience that I could not have done
anywhere else and I think a few things
that's that about it
one was the leaders were extremely
thoughtful and extremely vulnerable in
how they shared their own personal
stories and how that intersected with
the country and so I could see it not
only from my lens and my classmates but
also from the way they were viewing
things so for example one of the
students had attended Harvard and I
think he had had a scholarship there
earlier on is in his life and there was
a number it became actually a national
controversy at the time where people
were talking about like hey why are we
helping this person whose family had
come into the US illegally versus
someone who was born in the US and to
hearing him talk about that story and
then together as a group crossing the
border in Tijuana gave it a really
different experience and so I think like
the the global experiences I think
helped us really go to a much deeper
level and understanding each other and
then they were also extremely fun and we
went to like just great places who
wouldn't have been too otherwise and the
chance to spend so much time with each
other going through these
once-in-a-lifetime experiences I think
was one of the major ways that I made
some of my closest friends I'm gonna I'm
looking at the time and I'd like all of
you to give me a wrap-up comment and I
think
the quite one of the questions that came
in is if you had any words of advice so
if someone's admitted to the GSB and
you're looking back what advice would
you give them about coming to the school
so how about I'll start with you will
yeah sure thing well so first of all you
should definitely come I know some
people get into business school and
they're like oh like should I do it it's
definitely worth it and there was not a
single person I knew in my class who
didn't think it was worth it by like a
mile the one other thing I'd say it's it
makes a lot of sense to like plan in
advance because it is really like an
overwhelming experience there's so much
going on there's so many interesting
people to meet that I think it's really
helpful to have a sense of what you want
to get out of it and it's really okay if
what you want to get out of it is you
know trying something or testing
something that turns out to not be at
all what you want to do there's always
you know that's actually a really
helpful learning but I think it's worth
planning in advance and then the other
thing I think it's just like throwing
yourself in and not letting it slip I
mean when I look back at the GSB I have
very few regrets but the only things I
regret are like if anything not trying
to do more not making more time to do
all of those things because it is such a
unique to your experience surrounded by
incredible people with unlimited
resources and opportunities at your
disposal so I think you want to make the
most of that hey a DJ how about you give
us a rap on this question to please some
advice
I'm sure yeah so I think I would say
that let's see it's gonna say kind of
what bull was saying but I mean I think
being really open to new experiences you
know I mean I think people have
different comfort levels of how much
they want to try new things versus knob
versus kind of sticking with like the
types of classes that they know they'll
do well in or like the types of friends
that they used to have prior to business
school I just think that it's such an
opportunity to push yourself outside of
your comfort zone take that
that you don't have a background in at
all or you know spend time with people
who just aren't like the rest of your
friends so far there's never going to
really be another opportunity to do that
and it might surprise you in terms of
what you find that you like
I'm looking at the time anybody else
want to jump in
Eric Michelle or Jack with some advice
okay it's sort of similar but um yeah I
completely agree with the comments about
you know being open to a bunch of
different types experience but if
there's one thing that I can summarize
the last two years it's it is incredibly
busy and I think just having and and
have maybe a few things that you know
you really know you want to prioritize
and get involved in I think you know
just an example like for you know for
example like in the in the fall of you
know second year you're gonna see a lot
of your classmates recruiting for
consulting and for a while I was like
should I ever good for another
consulting firm you know but I was like
no no like I came here to do that and I
want to stay true to that and so I think
I'm kind of being your own person and
and focusing like I took like art
classes across the street even though
like you know no one else and it was
sort of doing that just the ability to
to focus and yeah like I said be your
own person I think is some good advice I
give that's awesome
Jackie we're not in your head did you
want to say one last thing as well yeah
just those resource priorities and and
[Music]
make sure you have it have a good system
for holding yourself to account I
remember you know week one student life
telling me about you know proactively
conjuring I can remember being sad I
going I'm a grown up I can manage my
current you know I used to turn
businesses around and then two days
later on my quadruple booked four times
in the same day and I felt it's like
challenging from a firehose so you know
have the roots as priorities find
somebody outside of the GSB to hold you
to account and somebody that you can
come back to and say okay do I really
need this brown bag lunch or am I just
going for the sandwich you know that's
close yeah so I'll see that's builds on
what a number of others
said which is what I said the main thing
is slow is smooth and smooth is fast
when you first come there can be an
incredible rush to do everything to try
everything to meet everyone and I
personally think that I would have gone
farther and gotten even more out of it
if I take the time to get to know each
person a little bit more if I take in
the time to think of it not as a
two-year sprint actually like two years
of meaningful chunk of life and there's
a lot that you can get done there if you
set yourself up where it's a way that
you could continue if it were the rest
of your life and so I think if you find
a way even if it's hard to prioritize to
slow down and spend that extra 30
minutes with someone versus 20 short
coffee chats or you spend that extra
time on that case to go deeper on it
that you may find that you'll learn more
quickly what it is that you want to do
and that ultimately leads you to knowing
more people who will stay close to your
heart so I'd encourage you to go slow to
go fast that's great well I think that's
a wonderful place to end I'm going to
share just a couple more slides but
wanting to thank Jack Michelle will do
key eret thank you so much for being
here so Stanford here's a quick picture
of our courtyard we call a Town Square
and the GSB buildings and when this
campus was built just eight years ago
the cornerstone actually says dedicated
to the things that haven't happened yet
and the people who are about to dream
them up and I think that really captures
the essence of Stanford we hope if
you've come today that you see yourself
as a big dreamer and you'll be
interested in learning more Stanford is
really built for people like you and if
you want to learn more you've got a
chance to hear from some of our
wonderful alumni but as I said earlier
feel free to book an information session
if you really want to think about
admissions and what we're looking for
there's also industry panels for
instance if you are looking for a career
in finance
come here from a whole panel of finance
alumni and students and then we have
added in the last 18 months some small
group chats which is really about ten
prospects with either an admissions
officer or students so it's a more
intimate environment where you can get
your individual questions answered
please if I didn't get there are many
questions in the chat if I didn't get to
yours you can also email us on the web
we appreciate that and just in closing
if you do come to Stanford we believe
that it will really open your really
open your horizons your self narrative
of what you can accomplish we think
it'll teach you to think boldly think
innovatively it'll help you develop your
leadership capabilities so others will
want to follow you and finally it will
help you define the path not just for
these next two years but for the next 40
years so you can see our mission and we
really try to live it at Stanford each
and every day so thank you so much for
joining us and have a good one
[Music]
you